One of the best supplements to take to help prevent colds in flu, we have a product that has
you know pretty much everything and it just to stimulate a normal healthy immune response
for colds and flu's and you know viruses so that's called our clear CD, clear CD for cold
and virus are what do we call this cold CD for? I don't know, not for corona virus, I know it wasn't
for me, but maybe so that was videos for sure getting a fan. So it but the clear CD is something
it's one of our bigger sellers it's got big skin, everything you need it you need to help for a virus
colds, flu's, to stimulate a healthy immune response. Obviously there's other things that I am
big into for your immune response that would be medicinal mushrooms, one of my favorite for cancer
because medicinal mushrooms really act as a immune regulator so if you're hyper immune so if a person
has an autoimmune disease you don't necessarily want to take on a like clear CD on a regular basis.
If you feel like a cold's coming out you feel like the flu's coming out taking it for a period of time
a week or two is fine but if you have an autoimmune disease you know you have poshimotos or you think
you have an autoimmune disease or you've been diagnosed with rheumatoid or something like that
then I would not take clear CD on a regular basis, taking mushrooms though can be safer
because they're not going to be this immune giant immune stimulator, it will be more of an
immune regulator so if your immune system is suppressed because of an infection then it will help build
that white blood cell backup, the cow backup and if it's overly expressed because of an immune
autoimmune issue it could help actually bring it down which is kind of nice so you don't get that
really hyper push of white blood cell cow with mushrooms unless it is suppressed and always
I don't think you should look at too and I forget to mention this is getting some blood work done
so getting a CDC and a complete metabolic panel done and if you're a course member of ours,
member you could order blood work off our course we don't mark it up at all and you get a local doctor
local to your state that signs off on it so it's all legal and everything and then you could go get
a blood draw I would highly recommend the complete wellness panel that gives you a complete CDC
complete metabolic panel complete thyroid panel and some other things that could be really beneficial
to really analyze an infection or not so if your white blood cell count is elevated beyond
7.5 or 8.0 you definitely have a a current infection and then you look at neutrophils and lymphocytes
to kind of give you some discernment whether it's a virus or a bacteria that gives you a good idea
how to best treat that as well so